my brother I've got two brothers one of
them now works with me but the middle
one he kept mentioning you Samuel this
Samuel that who the hell Samuel I looked
you up and then I you crash courses so I
was like right it's his birthday I paid
two quid and they took him as a surprise
down to see you at the end of the day I
was signing up to the academy and he
never joined wow what does he think now
of your journey in I'm not sure have you
spoke to him Rec yeah last thing he said
to my mother was how much dides she even
earn like he he's skeptical you mean
yeah I think he's still skeptical yeah
why do you think that is cuz he knew me
before yeah I was poor I was poor for
ages well Jesus says that Jesus says a
prophet has no honor in his hometown
yeah familiarity breathes contempt